[Music]
I'm an ant Agarwal and cheering our next
session we have a couple of very
exciting speakers for this March of
Technology session the first speaker
will be rod Brooks who was director of C
cell in the early part of this decade
he's also been a founder of a string of
successful robotics companies iRobot and
most recently Heartland robotics rod it
says that Rodney L Brooks is is speaking
and I don't know who he is I'm Rodney a
Brooks but well I'll impersonate so I'm
gonna talk about the march of technology
and and I'm gonna look back a little in
forward as everyone has done and you
know back in the old days
ordinary people couldn't touch computers
they were behind glass wolves mostly
because one of the reasons was people
were too dangerous for computers because
they all smoked back there and the smoke
particles got in the disk drive so you
had to seal the computers off from
people so they couldn't affect them and
if you were if you if you wanted your
information technology or information
that we would deliver and change you had
to go through a whole chain of people
systems analyst programmers punch card
operators etc you couldn't actually do
anything yourself but now only people
can touch computers and so there's been
this explosion over the last 30 years of
forms of computation and how we use it
and information that we get and we have
control I'm a robotics guy and robots in
factories today just like they were in
1961 when the first production lines
used robots in New Jersey and a GM plant
and ordinary people can't touch those
robots in this cases because the robots
are too dangerous and they will swing
around and kill someone without noticing
but what if or
people could touch robots and over the
last 10 years there has been the
transformation where they can now
ordinary people can touch robots and up
in the bottom top left side is a surgeon
using an intuitive surgical da Vinci
system to operate remotely inside the
patient when the surgeon moves their
fingers maybe a millimeter the robot
moves a fifth of a millimeter inside so
they can do much more delicate surgery
and the incision is much smaller you
might question whether a surgeon is an
ordinary person and they take that to
mean something different than the rest
of us when we say that but then then
there are home robots and I'm going to
talk about numbers in a minute on the
top right lots of lots of robots now in
people's homes there weren't any ten
years ago and on the bottom there's been
a transformation of US military over the
last ten years of not only air vehicles
and then air vehicles but also ground
robots and we see various things on the
bottom left a robot in Iraq improvised
explosive device remediation a robot
sniffing in the into a trunk of a car
looking for a bomb in the middle on the
bottom there you see a guy who came in
with his pack bot to a Depot in Iraq
that had been blown up he'd been out you
know defusing bombs and you see on the
on the that oh so he came in the robots
in a box in pieces he says I what can
you fix Scooby and the depo manager said
no but we can give you a new robot no no
I don't want a new robot I want Scooby
Scooby and I have been through a lot
together and you see on the back of
Scooby's head there I can make this work
I can't make that work the back of
there's a separate point okay on the
back of Scooby's head you see one
vehicle-based i ad 17 improvised
explosive devices and one unexploded
ordinance before Scooby blew up and now
we see the unmanned vehicles getting
into the infantry this is has just
started a program of record of putting
one robot with every troop of nine
soldiers in the US Army
so there's been a real change over the
last 10 years many of these robots are
from one of my companies but not all of
them where the ground robots in the US
military have gone from zero to over
9,000 ground robots and robots in
people's homes from zero to over six
million robots in people's homes that's
happened just in since the middle of
2002 and why is that happened why do we
have all these robots and all these
robot forms Oh before I say that I want
to say one thing because this is MIT
this is some of the robots that that
iRobot cells in non-consumer areas and
I'll come back you know there's a the
some of these and the some of these in
Fukushima right now at the nuclear power
plant this is a underwater sea glider
from University of Washington from where
Edwards Oscar is and these were out in
the Gulf looking at the oil spill last
year so not just military applications
but also other sorts of applications but
I meant to remember up here
Europe's one of the great things about
MIT is the undergraduate research
opportunities program with
undergraduates working with faculty and
this company iRobot was started by to
Europe's and me a faculty member and we
went out and started to come together
yesterday we had Tom Leighton talking
about Akamai again Europe's wind were
really part of that whole process of
starting the company and so that's one
of the great things about MIT call an
angle who's the CEO of iRobot likes to
point out then he's only ever had two
jobs with a regular paycheck one is camp
counselor and what a CEO of a company
anyway why have things taken off things
are taken off because computation and
senses have gotten exponentially cheaper
for the last 50 years we've heard that
exponential again and again I'm going to
come back to that in a second because
there's some key points there that I
think we that that explain what's
happened a little more research in
computer vision and things like
simultaneous localization and mapping
have made major strides in the last ten
years a lot of work that work has been
done MIT but also Stanford to other
places and for certain tasks robots have
passed to user
the threshold that makes them useful to
untrained people now oops
you do have to you have to press this
hard or long I'm not sure IT
exponentials we've we've said that again
again the last few days but it all comes
back to Moore's law and this is Gordon
Moore's paper from 1965 where he says in
the abstract there's a 10-page little
article with the unit cost falling as
the number of components per second rise
by 1975 economics may dictate squeezing
as many as 65,000 components on a single
chip and in the abstract the second
paragraph there he says this is gonna
lead to this is 1965 remember when a
computer cost a million dollars at least
and was filling a room a home computers
automatic controls for automobiles and
if anyone's you know used a 1965 or
previous automobile you know the weren't
much electronics in them back then and
best of all personal portable
communications equipment so he foresaw
all that and there was a cartoon in the
paper with a someone selling cosmetics
right next to a handy home computer
I asked Gordon in 2005 at a celebration
of 40 year celebrations paper whether
he'd had anything to do that cartoon he
said no not at all it just showed up in
the article my guess is the cartoonist
was sort of making fun of the idea of
having home computers but it turns out
to me what what really happened but this
is this is a Gordon's key graph he's
only got four data points this is the
null data point he plotted how many
components on a chip and had four data
points plotted against year and he just
extrapolate live in there extrapolate
more than ten years
of how many components that would be on
a chip and that comes out to two to the
16th or 65,000 well what's an
exponential an exponential is something
where the rate of change the amount of
stuff you've got is proportional to
instantaneous amount of stuff that you
have around already so is that why these
chips got more and more components was
because you had chips so you had
computers that you could design better
chips so that you could build bigger
chips and so on well David Mindell who
is running the whole MIT
150th in his name in his book Apollo
talks about the lunar module computer
and that was the first computer with
chips in the first the first in the
block one lunar module computer it was
one gate per chip then they upgraded to
two gates per chip an exponential
increase but that didn't come around
till 1968 so that's not why they exponet
this exponential took off originally and
it wasn't in play in 1965 in fact I
think there's three exponential forms
the rate of improvement is proportional
to the current level of adoption and
certainly network effects and uptakes of
Facebook and Twitter and all those
things that as old people don't use is
due to that but also the second one is
the existence the law tells everyone
what to aim for and I think that was a
driver in Intel and all the Japanese
memory companies you know the engineers
would walk past in the morning that plot
of how many bits they had to have on a
chip on what year and they'd know what
what technologies they needed to use or
thirdly someone else is driving an
exponential and you get to hop on it for
free and I'm gonna come back to that in
a minute but first I want to say this
thing about information technology and
Exponential's it's because there's a
special relationship between IT and
physics and that is that old digital
instantiation of information technology
are based on a one bit abstraction for a
bulk physical property of some sort we
heard yesterday you know that Shannon
said oh we can have an open or closed
circuit that's a one or a zero that's
where the electrons are flowing or not
it's a one bit abstraction so if you
want to you know look at these piles of
sand and tell which ones a red pile and
which ones a green pile a certain amount
of bulk physical stuff but you can take
away half you could make each of those
piles of sand half the size and they'd
still be piles of red sand of green sand
and then you could do it again and again
and again and the property stays
eventually get down to one grain and
then you have to go to multi-core but
so the physical bulk to be produced
while maintaining that abstraction
that's the important thing about
information technology and why you can
get Exponential's and Suzanne was
talking about some of the the new
technologies energy biotech etc and and
being very capital-intensive
I think the Sand Hill Road VC's got
spoiled by this and they saw thought
that any new technology would go
exponential but it doesn't have the same
relationship in energy for instance so
there are technologies all over the
place in information technology and then
those Exponential's beget other
Exponential's and so information
technology Exponential's are in
performance going up cost going down but
that's not true and other technologies
and my technology or my area robotics
it's not completely true this is a
family of robots from iRobot ranging
from 350 pounds these two are about 65
pounds this is 35 pounds and this is a 2
pound robot
they've all got much the same form but
their strength is not the same and their
speed is not the same if you've got a
mechanical arm and you cut off half of
it it gets weaker it can't compute
holding stuff up as well when you get
rid of the physical bulk so there's a
there's a relationship between
mechanical performance and the physical
bulk which is not there in IT likewise
in price one of my master students a few
years ago went around the lab and found
all the old McMaster mark master car
catalogs were lying around and he found
five components that we'd been using in
the lab for 13 years and looked at their
price and then normalized for the
consumer price index and they didn't go
down exponentially over those 13 years
they only just went down a few percent
so cost of mechanical systems likewise
doesn't go down exponentially cost of
energy systems doesn't go down
exponentially but if someone else is
driving an exponential maybe you can use
it for free and that's the good news for
robotics the IT Exponential's are good
for us they've been very very good to
robotics
few years and Exponential's help robots
in all sorts of places cameras vision
machine learning training corpus size
mirela go on the web and get lots of
examples and then train up your learning
algorithms etc and even the number of
cores on a chip and we aren't
necessarily in robotics have to be quite
as smart about having a general
programming methodology because we can
dedicate one quarter using the
processing sound and one quarter the
processing the left image in one quarter
processing the right image and we don't
have to have parallel programs at such
fine grain but Exponential's do impact
robots in 1979 when I was a grad student
at Stanford this is the old Stanford
artificial intelligence lab hands
Marivic had this project with a robot
called the cart and I was his junior
gopher and about midnight when most
people had gone home and the Dec 10
mainframe was available we'd set up this
room and set the robot going the flashes
are because this is being recorded on 16
millimeter film and the cameras stopping
so you'll see this thing slide across
this is the digital camera and it was
$50,000 so he couldn't afford two of
them so we had the mechanically slide it
to get stereo and then the robot would
look at those the processor would look
at those images compute for 15 minutes
and then move a meter so this is a six
hour run overnight getting the robot to
go 20 meters over six hours and around 6
a.m. we didn't even have our own
computer just for the AI lab then the
Center for computer research in music
came in at 6 a.m. and started composing
on the computer and the performance went
way down so that was the six hour window
so that's Stanford AI lab 1979 20 meters
in 6 hours
this camera by the way $50,000 recently
I saw a retail camera webcam for $2.99
so I bought it it came with the USB
cable for that price now it was a really
really lousy webcam but it was way
better than this 50 thousand dollar
camera so that's 1979 1992 I in
well one of my students had a had a
robot here
mighty Polly which would give tours of
the AI lab but when about 2,000 meters
in 6 hours on a typical day and by 2005
Sebastian's run head of the same lab as
the cart Stanford artificial
intelligence lab had his robot Stanley
go 200 kilometers across the desert in 6
hours so we see for as a magnitude
improvement over 26 years about a
doubling every 2 years 13 doublings and
so we see the exponential performance
increase in in these robots largely
driven by the exponential growth of
information technology and a few clever
algorithms here and there I claim the
world needs robots which is convenient
since I build them I'll just show you
one little piece here this is the
population of Europe in 1950 histogram
five year intervals on the left four men
five year intervals four women on the
right and this is what happens by 2000
and by 2050 this you know the snake
swallowed something and you see that
people are getting older so over the
next few years
edie as we baby boomers you know enter
retirement age not only is Social
Security gonna be stressed because we're
all pulling on Social Security but those
dollars have to be used to compete
amongst less workers to provide physical
services for us and I think that's
really gonna drive the use of robotics
to do physical stuff in the world
because the ratio of older the younger
people is changing dramatically not just
in Europe also the US Japan I just want
to show some finish with a few clips of
practical research in robots from some
of my students over the last few years
these and my PhD students but many
bachelors masters and postdocs have also
been involved and show you the sorts of
things that robots can do today so
here's this is actually a few years ago
here's a robot looking at this person's
eyes and when she looks somewhere the
robot figures out her gaze direction and
looks where she's looking okay
very different from the current
industrial
aware of the person aware how they're
interacting and if I was gonna show ed
how to do something I'd be looking at
his eyes all the time to see whether he
was paying attention to the to the right
thing and I'd be looking at his gaze
direction we use gaze direction as a
cute the good thing about robots is that
they can affect the world so if you want
to do a vision problem you want to see
what that object is against the
background you can move around and that
that that's segments it from the
background so you don't have to be you
know perfect on one image you can sort
of gets back to your thing about do your
best change the world you know push
things around change things and so
here's the here's the robot learning
about the appearance of an object which
looks much like the background that's
being put on but the robot pushes it
segments it and then in one shot gets a
view of the object which it can then use
to match later and you'll see over the
shoulder there looking inside its brain
it's it's model which is a 2d image
model of an object very different from
the way we use we people have models of
objects I'll get back to that in a
minute
and here integrating some of the speech
work from Jim glass and victor's news
group and I hope the sound is on
car
the car single-shot teaching of words if
it's more than one syllable takes few
more trials
ball now watch the robots eyes
and car it really knows where they are
it's gaze Direction ball refers to and I
just want to finish up with showing how
different current research robots are to
industrial robots industrial robots have
very little sensing the world don't know
what's going on don't know about people
but this is the robot Domo and Aaron ed
singer was the grad student who his work
this was and there is safely interacting
with the robot right in close to it
playing with it he's giving it objects
that it's never seen before
it it moves them around and it spins in
its view and gets the extent of them so
can manipulate it's aware of him it's
following him visually and here you see
the robot it's picked up this hammer
didn't know about the hammer before and
it moves it around and very quickly gets
its visual extent against a cluttered
background messy sort an environment and
is able to predict how it how it moves
around and then it's able to do tasks
and was just finished with that task
here it is putting a pipe in a in a hole
that knew nothing about before hasn't
seen these objects has no model builds
the model dynamically by looking at how
those things move against the cluttered
and maybe mobile background and then
there's an insertion in his actual in
his thesis defense he had the robot
making a margarita
okay so I'm gonna finish up with that
and just say that for me the challenge
is to make robots even better and easier
to work with get back to some of the
things patrick winston talked about
yesterday trying to make robots do
things the way humans do because
although we can do image based model
image based object recognition we can't
recognize classes we can't recognize
that this is a shoe if we've never seen
a black shoe that looks just like that
before whereas a two-year-old child can
tear a four-year-old child is able to
understand language in noisy
environments and be able to understand
lots of accents a six-year-old child
they will tie shoelaces and do every
task that is asked of a worker in a
Chinese factory and by the time the
child is actually nine but it makes more
fun to say eight here the child
understands the difference between what
they know and what other people know and
what other people know in terms of what
they the the child is able to keep track
of what the other person has seen and
what they know and how that differs from
their own model of the world whereas
when they're six years old they think
everyone knows exactly the same stuff as
they do so if you're looking for
challenges in robotics build these sorts
of capabilities or move towards these
sort of capabilities and we'll have more
and more of these robots that we are a
huged ed in his old age as he's getting
more and more decrepit thank you
[Applause]
we employee we're gonna do questions
dining any questions yeah so I see from
your talk that you've very optimistic
about the the progress of like robotics
and technology in general but you've
also expressed like skepticism with the
technological singularity so where do
you see things stopping I assume it does
stop at some point right well I I think
I think batlló was right in his talk
this morning that if you're a
materialist you have to believe that
uploading is is is technologically
possible but I think it's it's way too
early for us to worry about that I think
that's that sort of a you know a bunch
of technology people looking for eternal
salvation without the inconvenience of
having to believe in God
so I I think you know all of us not just
adding me but all of us here are gonna
die I mean it's just gonna happen it
sorry
I guess that that's it
[Applause]
Thank You rod the next at the next
session you'll see my robot come and do
this introduction it's my pleasure to
introduce John Hennessey so we'll talk
next John's the their president of
Stanford although I'm a little dubious
about his taste in graduate students I
was one of his early students in the
late eighties
but thank you or not I guess as somebody
told me recently of all the
introductions I've ever had that's the
most recent okay so I think as is
traditional in these sort of talks I'm
going to try to both take a look
backward and then a look forward and
talk about what the implications are the
march of technology isn't indeed a good
uber title for this talk because it
really is about the dramatic changes and
about the inflection point that we've
passed through and what some of those
implications are let's face it most of
the world is not going to use computers
the way those of us in my generation
have used computers I started on
actually paper tape and punch cards full
at a while and then moved to time
sharing but most of that time with a
computer that was at least on my desk
and not physically movable the next
generation is going to be using these
things to access the Internet and that's
the way they're gonna operate we've
already got this incredible inflection
point coming in in 2012 it may actually
move up into 2011 because the rapid
acceleration of tablets and if you put
tablets with smart phones which i think
is probably a reasonable thing to do
their mobile devices they're small then
we may actually get the crossover in in
2011 and desktops are fading in this
whole picture so it's happening very
quickly that means the growth in in CPUs
is actually being driven by that low-end
plus of course this enormous consumption
of computers in the cloud as we build
these giant warehouse scaled computers
that are providing much of the storage
backup content information for the for
the web so what happens now batteries
become crucial energy becomes a key
factor in determining how useful these
devices are and if you look at whether
you look at
later you look at a a cellphone you
quickly discover that energy becomes the
limiting factor how long does this last
I don't think certainly you start using
the web a lot on this it doesn't last
very long and that's a key issue so
battery life time is crucial
which means energy consumption becomes a
crucial metric by the way it does in the
cloud too if you look at the initial
capital cost this piece of it in red
here is the cost of power and cooling
that's just capital cost that's the
infrastructure to bring up a large size
cloud if you then look at the overall
operational cost you see the power here
combined with the capital amortization
of the infrastructure is a significant
piece of that puzzle and any of anybody
who's looked through the kinds of clouds
that are being built by Google or Yahoo
or others the first thing you'll notice
is they're not using the cutting-edge
fastest processor because as you'll see
the cutting-edge fastest processor is a
disproportionate power Pig its energy
inefficient and I'll talk some about why
that's the case so we're sort of back
we're in this age now where we're really
back to the future we rode Moore's law
and computer architects that's what I
did for a living when I was doing that
before I was a university president a
computer architects basically have had
one function for quite some time
we take Moore's law and the magic of
this doubling of transistors that's been
given to us by the integrated circuit
industry and we try and turn it into
performance that's usable by the kinds
of software systems that we right now so
if you think about what happened in the
early late 70s and early 80s when the
RISC movement was about it was really
about efficiency in the end it was how
do we take these transistors and use
them effectively given that we're going
to be on a single chip how does that
reset the picture for how we build
computers that freed up by by
simplifying the
action set without losing very much
translational efficiency between the
software systems we picked up a lot of
transistors that could then be used to
do pipelining caches etc and we gained
runtime efficiency I think early on
people realize that if you could spend a
little more time at compilation time and
less at runtime that that was a good
trade-off for production oriented
environments so what did we learn in the
in the 1980s well we really discovered
that the ability of these simpler
instruction sets to exploit instruction
level parallelism was substantially
better than the more complex instruction
sets and that's really what allowed us
then to get on what I would call the
instruction level parallelism rote path
and it was a road map that was going up
like this like gangbusters and every
year we were just getting more
instruction level parallelism
introducing new ideas to extract more of
it and thereby being able to deliver
lots of new performance without changing
the software model of course one of the
things we discovered there that I think
none of us suspected when we started now
I still remember putting this on the
slides that we pitched to the venture
capitalists when we started MIPS we said
the emergence of high-level language and
Unix
would make software portability much
better than it had ever been and
therefore new architectures would be
easy to introduce what we missed of
course was the emergence of shrink-wrap
software and the shrink-wrap software it
came out and it meant that carrying that
software burned along getting the
independent software vendors to move to
your new architecture was absolutely
crucial and that was hard to do so
silicon and power almost unlimited in
the 1990s we rode that instruction level
instruction level parallelism path
caches became gigantic we got lots of
performance and then things changed what
happened well two things happened at the
same time the immersion of the embedded
embedded world and what I would call
personal mobile devices becoming
widespread
efficiency became critical even if the
high-end desktop energy efficiency
became crucial the amount of power we
could get in and out of the chip became
a limiting factor in how we designed it
I mean imagine now you go and buy an
Intel Core i7 it has a detector on there
that slows the clock rate down if the
chip gets too hot you can write a
workload which will cause that to come
on fact you can actually write a
workload that'll turn the processor
completely off if it gets near the
critical junction temperature so
Energy's the key the tough thing about
energy is that the power consumed is
proportional to how many transistors
you're switching every clock cycle times
the clock cycle right if you think about
the dilemma that provides to computer
architects it's somewhat it says
basically you speed up the clock you
consume more power you switch more
transistors you consume more power what
this really says is that one needs to
think about energy efficiency in a whole
new way because either way you advance
performance you're going to pay more but
if you do it more efficiently it'll work
better than otherwise so a few people
predicted that the amount of instruction
level parallelism was unlimited and
therefore we would just keep extracting
more and more and more and this road
path would continue forever well the
answer is yes there's lots of
instruction level parallelism but
exploiting very much of it is just
tremendously inefficient and that
insight holes in lots of different ways
it holds whether you try to do it
statically or dynamically I think we've
tried lots of different techniques and
run into the same roadblock I'll show
you why just quickly here's a bunch of
random programs how much instruction
level parallelism is there if you have
ideal speculation by ideal speculation I
mean you know a priori the outcome of
every single branch therefore you can
run arbitrarily far ahead in the code
and any instruction which doesn't depend
on instruction X can be operated in
parallel with instruction X remember
that ideal speculation so there's lots
of parallelism here 18 for the slowest
one but 150 in scientific code GCC 55
instructions per clock I mean that's
incredible if we ever got there that's a
factor of probably 20 better between 20
and 30 better than we can actually do
well what happens well when you start to
make the amount of look head finite the
number drops very quickly okay so that's
the first problem you run into and the
reason is lots of there's lots of
locality and dependence and computation
when you look across a short stream so
you see this number falling down very
quickly the other problem is that
speculation basically hits some
fundamental very difficult limits to
overcome and this shows you interesting
data just recently collected actually on
a Intel i7 that shows you what fraction
of the work the instructions that
actually get sent to the processor are
actually wasted and you see it's 25
percent 30 percent 20 percent here now
remember every instruction that gets
wasted you paid an energy cost to
execute that instruction essentially all
of it now you pay an energy cost to undo
the effects of this instruction that you
should not have done and that's what
happened we basically speculation just
couldn't get good enough to overcome
these kinds of limits and of course it's
a probability thing if you're if you're
90 percent successful on the first
branch and 90 percent on the second
branch then you're only 80 percent on
getting both of them right and that just
overcomes the advantages that
speculation have has after a short
amount of time so what happened so we
started thinking about multi-core and
threads and switching to thread level
parallelism as the key issue it has lots
of advantages it's an effective way to
overcome the memory wall and on did a
lot of work in this particular area
early on using multi-threading we can
exploit it in lots of ways both through
simultaneous multi-threading
multi-threading within a single core as
well as by going to multi-core and
Moore's law helps Duke makes this easy
in fact there was a great quote that
somebody said at one conference they
said multi-core makes Moore's law
now the programmers problem it's not
quite the right metaphor but the
metaphor was you now have to worry about
getting performance efficiency it's not
the CPU designers problem anymore but
the big questions are can
multi-threading and multi-core deliver
more performance in an efficient fashion
so here is some fascinating data showing
you the performance and energy
efficiency for a simultaneous SMT so
simultaneous multi-threaded single core
running with two threads versus running
with one thread the thing you'll notice
so performance we get a performance
boost which goes anywhere from 1 down
here not very much on a few programs to
numbers up to close to 2 so it's running
close to twice as fast as it would by
multi-threading 2 threads on a single
core but look at the energy numbers the
energy numbers are actually pretty good
and in fact in some cases this is
actually energy efficiency has been
gained meaning the two threads running
on a single core or actually complete
the computation with less total energy
expended which is an amazing insight
this would never happen for ILP it
doesn't happen when you try to do simply
two instructions per clock you can't get
this result so it's an interesting
insight that we're able to do that but I
should say these programs are Java
programs these are a bunch of things
from the parsec benchmark sets so these
what you might call modern
computationally intensive programs
so now what about when you go to
multi-core does this trend continued in
multi-core and the answer is sometimes
this is a more complicated chart here
I've lumped together the parsec
benchmarks and the Java benchmarks speed
up here and energy efficiency over here
so notice that when the speed-up is very
good as it is in the case of the parsec
benchmarks then the energy efficiency is
good when you get less speed-up of
course you then see a lower level of
energy efficiency so for some of these
benchmarks in the case of jut the Java
benchmarks because you get less speed-up
there's less of a reduction in execution
time there's more power consumed in a
multi-core environment so you're paying
more power the result is that you don't
necessarily get an improvement in energy
efficiency nonetheless most CPU
designers would agree that compared to
any alternative that's available in the
instruction level parallelism benchmark
arena any alternative this is still
better from an efficiency viewpoint when
you combine them you get sometimes you
get the advantages sometimes you don't
the problem of combining SMT and
multi-core now is if you have a four
core machine with two threads per core
you need eight levels of parallelism in
order to really keep it busy and if you
don't have that then of course you pay a
high or penalty and you actually see
this kind of fall-off here when the
speed-up isn't very good is what happens
in these Java benchmarks so where are we
we're in a we're in an interesting state
now where there's essentially two
divisions two different ways to go
forward with multi-core based designs
one that uses fine grained
multi-threading this has sort of been
the future that Sun Niagra is pursuing
and possibly could be something that
Intel might pursue in a future processor
designed more for the embedded and
mobile market than for the PC market and
we've got things
like the intel i7 and lots of processors
that are over here that use some amount
of speculation multiple issue three to
four issues per clock aggressive memory
hierarchies and tackle the problem that
way scientific computing guys are off in
a different realm they're off trying to
figure out what to do with GPUs and
someday GPUs will be designed by CPU
designers and then maybe the problem
will get fixed but we're not there yet
so a couple concluding thoughts about
this we're moving in the Durrett in this
direction there's no going back there's
no other viable alternative on the
horizon we are going to have to accept
the fact that if you want more
performance you're going to get it by
more cores on a chip and the software
people are going to have to figure it
out well it's sort of back to the future
this is a wonderful quote that's in
David cooks oral history talking about
the iliac 4 on the iliac 4 he was not
only the head software person he was the
software person on the iliac for
responsible for the system software so
you see what happened a bunch of
hardware designers said well if we build
the hardware the software will work and
of course that's not what happened it
turned out to be a very difficult
machine to program even even for a
narrow range of applications it was hard
to use although it did work quite well
for a subset of those but it's a
reminder that that interaction between
software and hardware is a fundamental
part of the problem so going back to
some of the points that were made
earlier and I absolutely agree with what
Barbara Liskov said earlier programming
multiple processors in ways that are not
impossibly difficult which today one can
debate whether the impossibly difficult
but they're close it's close once
somebody told me it's not hard to
program multi processors and I said it's
not hard if I don't care about
correctness and I don't care about
performance
programming multiple processors in ways
that are not possibly difficult retain
some degree of portability across
architectures so that we don't have to
turn every single programmer into a
hardware architecture expert
understanding things like the size of
caches levels at which coherency are
done multiple levels of interconnect and
how they operate which today if you
really want to push the performance
those are all things you have to become
aware of have some flexibility across
processor count variation so today we
have a dilemma that many pieces of code
work fine if they're written for four
threads but work marginally on eight and
don't work on sixteen we need to do a
better job of thinking about how we get
scalability and write our code and of
course achieve efficiency because in the
end the reason I was willing to use some
kind of multi processor was to get more
performance and I have to get that
efficiency I think this is in the
computer systems area one of the truly
most difficult problems we're more than
a decade behind and we're more than a
decade behind because everybody was
dreaming that that ILP roadmap would
continue into the far future and we
wouldn't have to solve this problem
unfortunately for better or worse the
investments were not made in in really
trying to focus on this problem I agree
with I think Barbara hinted at earlier
there likely is no silver bullet here
there's no one thing that's going to
crisply solve the problem but I also
believe that there is great opportunity
and that it's going to take somebody who
is in the next generation of computer
scientists to solve this problem so I
urge the young people to think hard
about what they might do to solve this
problem
the person who solves this problem will
really propel the industry along and
we'll all be grateful because we all
have faster machines that do all the
great things we want to do thank you
[Applause]
we have time for a couple of questions
so I'm very interested in this challenge
and I was wondering you about your
insights about what would be the most
potential or the most suitable level at
the software stack to solve or to
address this challenge and I think it
will probably get solved at multiple
levels on the software stack I think the
sort of MapReduce is one model for one
class of problems that have lots of
natural high level parallelism and can
be divided into tasks which are more or
less identical run across that but it's
not an adequate model for all our
applications I think we're going to have
to have fundamental progress in terms of
methodology that eventually gets coded
into some language support mechanisms
and a programming environment we're
gonna need that and I think it's not
enough it's not enough to just have this
very high level parallelism works fine
if you're searching the world wide web
works fine if you're running large
database queries but the truth is I want
my little tiny device here to have a
user interface which is absolutely
spectacular so that I talk to it under
all kinds of situations it filters out
all the background noise it figures out
what to do and it really makes my life
better that is not going to be coded in
that kind of application environment so
I think we're going to have to work on
the language and program methodology as
well I appreciate your comments about
the parallel processing but I had a
question about the processor
architectures and how they would evolve
in the future in particular how do you
see changes in microprocessor
architectures with the different
applications such as data centers versus
mobile devices yes so we are seeing some
divergence I actually threw a slide out
of this to save some time actually I
probably the next slide in the order
if they put the thing if they put it
back up and they've taken off okay I
probably put it in as a backup slide oh
here it is so this shows you two
different microprocessors and this is a
this is a phenomenal opportunity that
only comes along once in a great while
two processors same instruction set
architecture same compiler same
implementation technology so now we get
to compare two different organizational
approaches to performance okay one is
the is Intel's high-end i7 the other is
the atom 230 which is in a lot of the
very low-end netbooks okay so look at
this so you look at the incredible
performance advantage the i7 has four at
a minimum three or four times up to
seven eight times so you say it's that
much faster it must be a much better
processor well not if you're metric is
energy it's worse by about a factor of
two in terms of energy consumption so I
think we are seeing it when you see this
data it immediately tells you there may
be a split in how we design things for
the very low end where we really care
about energy and some things where we
care a bit about performance and we're
willing to give up on energy efficiency
in order to get that performance and
that split maybe coming it just may be
unavoidable
so what meters are coming in to use as
we try to save energy at home correct
but I as a software engineer
have to run a separate profiler to
figure out where my time is being wasted
and I have almost no introspection as to
where my power is being wasted yep how
can we instrument the world in such a
way that now that speed is my problem as
a software engineer that I have the
tools to attack it yeah that's a very
good question
this data that was actually collected on
energy was actually collected by hooking
up watt meters to computers because
the the rated power doesn't tell you
anything about these processors because
the max power is not equal to the
thermal design power is not equal to the
actual power consumption they're all
different measurements so in order to
figure out how much power is actually
being consumed you have to hook up a
watt meter right now so there's now this
notion that we should have inside the
processor just as we have now all these
measurements that tell us what the
speculation this ratio is what the
branch misprediction is what the cache
miss rates are what the power
consumption is and I think if we had
that we could actually then begin to
think about this issue and I think if
you care about low-power devices you're
going to have to contemplate what it
means okay okay thank you
[Applause]